i'm so glad you came today we have a
fantastic show for you we're going to
get right into it but i'm just making up
this holiday of bringing your
nearest and dearest to work today
because two of my nearest and dearest
are sitting right here in the front row
that's anna galino and francesca de la
fuente who actually married a man named
de la vega so technically she's
francesca de la fuente de la vega
all right we've got a bunch of
interesting headlines so let's do it
let's get some news you can use
all righty then it's time for drew's
news your good news hot pocket stuffed
with pipe and hot stories and with me at
the desk a man who knows you gotta cut
that pocket open and let her cool first
rossi ross matthew you got to blow in
that pocket
you don't want to burn that time done
that before i'm not gonna do it again
yes all right let's get into our first
story everyone's got their bibs on and
forks and knives out for adele yes
because her new album is out this friday
but guess what
guess who swooped in early to serve up a
surprise feast taylor swift
she got right in there and the boston
globe reports that she just released her
re-recorded red album and it stacked
it's got 30 tracks clocking in at over
two hours of music
and then she hit us with a 10-minute
performance of all too well on snl this
weekend
and released not one but two new videos
one directed by tayte herself and the
other by friend and collaborator blake
lively ross not only would taylor what
is she going to do next but do we think
she sleeps i know right so this is what
taylor did during the pandemic girl take
a day off
do you feel like right we're lazy
compared to her and that 10-minute song
all too well so this was the song that
is going to be about can we go there
rumored well i think we all know who
it's about
rhymes with hake bilen hall yes
so i woke up sunday morning and trending
on twitter was jake gyllenhaal and of
course i clicked to see why imagine if
you were him though it's just another
sunday good morning
you're like why am i trending on twitter
i had a jake gyllenhaal incident tell me
everything well we produced johnny darko
which was like his first you know film
that he was in um and but i went on
james corden and they have that like eat
your guts or spill your guts that game
where you have to eat like eyeballs and
end trails and it's just so disgusting
but he they made me like list out actors
like in order of favoritism which is
just so screwed yeah you're just gonna
lose so i put jake last because i i was
adam sandler
i'm not going to put him last no
i was i was screwed so then i had to
walk down a carpet with like a picket
sign saying i love jake gyllenhaal
because did you hear from him um no
um
he's fine he and i are great um
but um our next story has to do with the
taylor swift ex-boyfriend and i think
they're amicable i think so we're
talking about uh
harry styles
i love harry styles because he's he's
like simultaneously like a super sweet
and kind of a bad boy and i know
i can relate
and he's now harry styles is getting
into the beauty business welcome to the
club right days magazine reports his new
beauty brand is called pleasing
and you can pre-order yours now harry
starting with four plant-based nail
polish shades which and we have them
love the packaging and by the way we got
this early from their pr office these
are not out yet i really love this this
is very beautiful well i love it too i
mean i love everything that he does and
um he also has this skin what is this
it's a serum it's a serum yeah and i
mean i think the packaging looks really
really beautiful yeah and this is an eye
roller look you do like this on your
skin do i look like harry styles
i think you look great thank you
um oh yeah see look there which one is
ross which one is harry try to figure it
out
me i'm ross okay next up when i shop
online i love to do my research and
there's nothing i love more than a
brutally honest review check this out
the good news network reports that a
woman named corey left a rave review for
her ray pose exercise leggings now this
is a woman after my own heart this is
exactly what i look like when i work out
apparently she wore them on a hike she
climbed up the mountain and then when
she got up there she was like oh my god
what am i going to do how am i going to
get down so she butt slid the hallway
and
leggings
didn't even rip not a tear so she shared
the photographic evidence and wrote can
i just say that i'll be reordering these
in every color uh-huh
now that
that that is a review do you need
leggings to slide down a mountain do i
have the leggings for you i mean
never thought i needed that but thank
you so much yes
what's going on just patting this down
oh um do you ever leave reviews no um
yes but i'm anonymous
oh wait okay tell me about a review you
left well um oh well okay well
i don't want to admit the things you say
and do do you no because i'm not a
complainer in real life like i like to
you're not no i live next to you you're
such a good person i don't complain in
the moment right because i don't want i
hate confrontation right you fester and
then explode afterwards well i fester
and then create an anonymous like yelp
account and then let my frustration out
when i get home right i and i will say
in my defense i don't just leave bad
reviews i leave good reviews too okay
and i feel like i'm guiding other
consumers and you're welcome you are
welcome for my yelp reviews i need it i
stand by them hey guess what what
um
don't
uh give an option for reviews if you
don't want them
you've been warned yes all right hey
moving on you know turkey day are you
ready it's just around the corner
sorry rossi you were saying okay so it's
turkey day yes and we have a big debate
for all of you when you serve that big
feast do you do it family style or do
you do it buffet
now you know this drew i love a buffet
and i'll tell you why i when it's in the
center of the table i see you looking at
the piece that i want right and then
it's a competition when when it's a
buffet there's no one judging how much i
put on my plate there's just a wall in
front of me and i'm in charge and that's
why i like it okay well
point counterpoint i feel like we're
giving reviews right now which this is
really fun i'm gonna give the devil's
advocate here and say that i hate
buffets and i'll tell you why
first of all don't have everybody know
i'm going back for seconds and thirds
and fourths
we get along so well about most things
but buffets are the big divider between
the two of us
you're concerned that i'm watching you
go up for a second or third trip girl
i'm not watching you i'm busy getting my
own food okay
so we are we disagree but you know who
might be able to marry our ideas
together we turn to always for the
answer in a garden yep uh the barefoot
contessa appar apartment therapy reports
uh she's buffet all the way what i
didn't even know okay she agrees with me
uh she said she says it allows for an
easy breezy dinner flow and avoids the
awkward passing of the plates so um
barefoot contessa and i uh we are on the
same page sorry drew
[Music]
you